This is the town of Staufen, near
the Black Forest in south-west Germany.
And as you walk around,
it looks like a normal German town
with one strange addition.
Up on some buildings,
there is a big fake piece of sticky tape
with a slogan that translates as
"Staufen must not fall apart".
Unfortunately, it's a bit late for that.
The government here tried to
bore for geothermic energy
and they bored, in total,  seven boreholes
right behind the town hall.
Underneath of Staufen is
a big layer of anhydrite
and underneath that is a layer of groundwater
in a confined aquifer.
The pressurised groundwater
went into the layer of anhydrite
and formed gypsum
which expands by about 50%.
Unfortunately, that means that the ground
is expanding, bulging up,
and forming cracks in almost every
single house that's standing here.
It took two weeks for the
first cracks to appear.
In the decades since
the drilling operation
the town hall has risen
more than half a metre
and moved sideways by
about the same amount.
And that might not sound like
much, and yes, if everything
had shifted evenly it might
not even be a problem.
The trouble is that different
parts of each building
have shifted by slightly
different amounts.
Modern buildings couldn't cope with that,
and that town hall was built in 1546.
The result is cracking.
There's water from this confined aquifer
that's pushing up the boreholes.
And what they are trying
to do is get the water out,
get the pressure down
from the confined aquifer
so that it doesn't even want
to go up those holes anymore.
So they are pumping at a speed
of around a litre per second.
The swelling started with
about a centimetre per month,
now it's down to about
a millimetre per month.
But it's still swelling, and even a millimetre
is still way too much for every house.
Theoretically, they can stop it,
but you cannot just
plug it like a bathtub.
It's not a single plane.
It's more three dimensional, so in reality
you would need a big, big plug
and you don't even know where it exactly is.
The drilling company settled out of court
for more than €1m,
but the cost of the damage here
is estimated at more than 50 times that.
And there are eight other German towns
with similar problems.
Geothermal drilling was popular
and not massively regulated.
And while the industry and the country
have learned from those mistakes,
for this town that knowledge comes
a little too late.
Thank you very much to
Constantijn Crijnen,
he suggested this video
in the first place.
He also has his own YouTube
channel where he's building
a 3D printer from
scratch, go check him out.